foreign
gather round one and all I have a
festive tale to tell it's the Christmas
story but not the one you know you see
there are other versions out there
hidden ones ones that are not included
in the Bible and perhaps for good reason
they're strange very strange from
bizarre miracles to frightening monsters
these festive stories add new details to
the Nativity details that have long been
overlooked this is the Christmas story
that never was this is Christmas in the
apocryphal Gospels
[Music]
the biblical Christmas story is from the
gospels the New Testament books about
the life of Jesus there are four gospels
in total but only two of them describe
Jesus's miraculous birth Matthew and
Luke each tells a very different version
of the same story Matthew's gospel has
the bright star and the wise men Luke's
gospel has the chanting angels and the
Shepherds together they make up one
Christmas narrative despite the two
versions the biblical Christmas story is
very short only a few chapters or so
combined we also hear next to nothing
about Jesus as a child what else
happened that fateful Christmas night
enter the apocryphal gospels a group of
Christian writings that didn't make it
into the Bible many of them have their
own versions of the Christmas story like
the infancy Gospel of Thomas the history
of Joseph the Carpenter and the
amazingly named proto-evangelium of
James they give us expanded accounts of
the Nativity with some bonus details
about Jesus as a child they fill in the
narrative gaps left by the Bible a bit
like biblical fan fiction in fact that's
exactly what it is the word apocryphal
means something hidden these gospels
have been dismissed as either dubious or
theologically controversial like the
gospel of pseudo-matthew a document that
claims to be a long-lost piece of
Matthew's gospel but what do these
hidden stories actually say what do the
apocryphal gospels add to the Christmas
story let's take a closer look at them
and retell the birth of Jesus as told in
these banned biblical books
Our Story begins on the outskirts of
Bethlehem Mary and Joseph have just
arrived in time for the Roman census
Mary is heavily pregnant no surprise who
the baby is and Joseph is eager to find
a midwife to help with the birth
suddenly the Skies open up and a
mysterious Angel descends from Heaven it
tells Mary not to go to Bethlehem and
instead Venture into that dark gloomy
cave over there without questioning this
Mary follows the Angel's commands and
proceeds into the cave Joseph doesn't go
with her and instead heads into the town
in search of a midwife or two Mary is
left in the cave all by herself and
tries to get comfortable on the cold
Stony floor all of a sudden the cavern
is filled with a glow that illuminates
the surroundings a baby miraculously
appears on Mary's lap Jesus only a few
seconds old he's able to stand fully
upright
in the skies above the Cave the Angels
begin chanting and singing hailing the
birth of the Divine infant glory to God
in the highest
and on Earth peace to Men of good
pleasure
realizing he's just missed the birth of
his child Joseph rushes back into the
cave he's managed to find two midwives
in Bethlehem but it's a bit late now hey
at least he tried the two midwives
observe the newborn baby and are
surprised that he's already able to walk
one of them Salome is not yet convinced
this is the actual Son of God she walks
over to Mary and inspects the child as
she continues to doubt the infant her
hand shrivels up and becomes withered
but baby Jesus gently touches her hand
and it's miraculously restored three
days later Mary takes the baby out of
that dark cave and heads down to the
nearest stable why so a cow and a donkey
can get a good look admittedly it's an
odd thing to do until you realize that
it's meant to fulfill a prophecy from
the Old Testament Isaiah 1 3 the ox
knows its owner and the donkey its
Master's crib we are told that the
animals are very happy to see Jesus they
quote adore him
that's nice
at this point the story jumps ahead two
years three wise men have come looking
for Jesus about time the men bring gifts
of gold frankincense and myrrh just like
in the Bible but they also bring a few
other things specifically 12 commanders
who bring a legion of a thousand
soldiers each safe to say things got a
little crowded in Bethlehem that day
after the wise men and their armies
leave toddler Jesus goes for a stroll
around the nearby caves his anxious
parents following closely behind out of
the Gloom comes a rumble and a group of
ferocious dragons appear unfazed in the
slightest toddler Jesus walks up over to
them and smiles the dragons are Charmed
by him and decide to slink back into the
cave this strange episode has just
fulfilled another Old Testament prophecy
Psalm 148 7 praise the Lord from the
earth ye dragons and all deeps this
Niche biblical reference is totally lost
on Mary and Joseph they're
understandably shaken up by the whole
ordeal toddler Jesus turns to them and
slowly utters his first Words Be not
Afraid and do not consider me to be a
little child
for I am and have always been perfect
and all Beasts of the forest must be
tame before me
news of this eloquent Dragon taming
toddler gets around town and soon
arrives in the court of King Herod he's
nervous especially as they've started to
call him King of the Jews to be on the
safe side Herod orders a massacre of all
infants under the age of two actually
this spits in the Bible as well but it's
too dark to feature in any of the songs
just like the Bible story Mary Joseph
and Jesus flee Bethlehem for Egypt
things get apocryphal again when they
arrive at an orchard on Route swaying in
the breeze is a tree with delicious
looking fruit trouble is it's Out Of
Reach toddler Jesus hops off Mary's lap
and begins speaking again oh Tree Bend
thy branches and refresh thy mother with
thy fruit as if it were a Christmas
miracle the tree obeys Jesus and curls
down Mary plucks its fruit and is
replenish by the well-needed snack and
with that our apocryphal Christmas story
comes to an end
the apocryphal gospels follow the basic
plot of the biblical Nativity a baby is
born in miraculous circumstances men
show up with gifts and a massacre of
infants takes place the stories
featuring Dungeons and Dragons add all
sorts of curious details to the main
story shame none of them are considered
official that said have you noticed the
illustrations I've been using throughout
this video artworks that seem to be
based on the apocryphal gospels like
this Renaissance painting where baby
Jesus is standing upright or this German
manuscript of toddler Jesus taming a
dragon what about this stained glass of
the tree giving Mary its fruit somehow
details from the apocryphal gospels have
snuck into depictions of the Christmas
story why these stories aren't in the
Bible so what are they doing in Biblical
Art throughout the history of
Christianity these apocryphal stories
were very popular in fact they were
often read alongside the Bible
particularly the gospel of
pseudo-matthew that non-biblical book
attempting to pass off as a lost piece
of the original in medieval Europe many
believed that it was actually part of
the Bible its Tales of dragons talking
babies and obedient trees were
mistakenly seen as canonical it was
quite literally reader's gospel these
bonus details are not part of the
biblical Canon but they are part of the
visual Canon imagine a nativity scene
without a stable or a cow and donkey
there's no mention of any of these in
the biblical version but they are still
commonly found in religious art and not
just in the Medieval Era elements from
these apocryphal gospels have been found
on Roman carvings dating to 385 of a d
next time you go to a school Nativity
and see children dressed up as these
animals politely remind those around you
that they are not biblically accurate if
we're going to include apocryphal
creatures where's the kid dressed up
like a dragon
the official Christmas story in the
Bible is very brief so delving into
these unofficial texts reveal colorful
extra details it's biblical fan fiction
after all who doesn't like learning
about their favorite heroes from the
Christian scriptural universe nowadays
we've largely forgotten that these
hidden stories even exist but they've
always been there especially in
religious art had the apocryphal gospels
been included in the Bible they would
have dramatically changed how the
Christmas story is told Christmas has
always been a mishmash of a bunch of
festive Traditions the date December
25th is taken from an ancient Roman
Festival decorated pine trees from
Baltic paganism and a yule log from the
Vikings with such a multicultural and
collaborative myth as Christmas it's
nice to know these amazingly underrated
stories have a place at the table
and that concludes my festive tale but
before you go I come bearing a gift have
you ever wanted to hear more from me
like say an eight-episode investigative
podcast well you're in luck introducing
the interruption it's all about a
strange incident in 1977 where
television sets across Southern England
were hijacked by a mysterious voice a
voice claiming to be from outer space
[Music]
for 45 years it has remained unsolved
well until now you can listen to the
interruption right now wherever you get
your podcasts links are down below it's
a truly absurd story and I think you're
going to love it a little gift from me
to you apocryphaly yours ochilago
hey thanks for watching I had a great
time making this and I hope you enjoyed
it too if you like this video and want
to see more why not subscribe a like and
a comment also go a really long way oh
and do check out the Channel's merch
over at crowdmaid we have beanies
t-shirts and hoodies links are in the
description down below
I look forward to seeing you next time
goodbye